yeah we got some trailers coming at us
and if there's something that can get me
to do a video it's pretty much born
James Bond actually that might not be
true I didn't do a video on the teaser
trailer for Skyfall I just felt like
there wasn't enough there for me to talk
about I think I was doing a lot of other
stuff nonetheless so let's talk about
this trailer for Skyfall because it's
bond and this trailer is cool for the
fact that it's just James Bond chasing a
dude down you know it's all really
intense take the bloody shot wait whoa
whoa that chick just shoot James Bond
and was it on purpose when Emma's like
take the bloody shot was she's saying
kill James Bond or did that chick just
miss because if she totally whiffed it
and killed James Bond something tells me
if she's taking a pay cut you don't kill
Bond [ __ ] that's the world we live in
escort the Queen to the Olympics get
wasted and the story in this one is
there's a hard drive that had all the
names of all the agents at mi6 and
because that chick blew away James Bond
the bad guys got away with it now it's
out on our hometown of YouTube and no
James Bond to stop them and then
unbeknownst to em but pretty much
absolutely known to us James Bond comes
back double-oh-seven reporting for duty
but he'll of you be enjoying death Lucci
I'm not gonna lie if everyone thought I
was dead you bet I'd be taking shots and
trapping scorpions in my shot glass that
is living and then you see it the
greatest terror that's ever flapped in
any night of any James Bond movie do you
know
no not that chick that chick is way hot
fact who is that chick that olivia munn
looking chick not bad I know it's not
even Javier Bardem who is the bad guy in
this movie who plays terrifying very
well and I'm psyched to see him as a bad
guy in a James Bond movie this guy might
be the most menacing Bond villain ever
one of anyway he's gonna be business but
no the real terror in this movie is
Javier Bardem hair she send you up to me
know when you're not ready know when you
would likely die mommy was very bad look
at that dude it's alive it's like he
broke into NIC cages wardrobe and just
snatched some of his wigs and you're
like this one will do yeah it's
something else and the wrap up in this
trailer there's just a bunch of badass
Bond scenes with the Bond music going
which is what makes bond bond I am
pumped for this movie I loved Casino
Royale I was like they brought barn down
to a believable level it wasn't so campy
it was just all badass and Daniel Craig
is James Bond in my personal yet not so
humble opinion but still my opinion is
the best James Bond sorry Sean Connery
lovers out there he's great he's iconic
Daniel Craig best bond ever favorite
part of the trailer though is among this
montage of badassery this train gets
ripped in half and he's just like boom
lands check the cuff links alright let's
kick ass
yeah and there's also some elements if
they really touch on it could be really
interesting James Bond's faked his death
for god knows how long is he rusty now
he shoots his target pretty sure the
bullseye is not on the edge I like it
when people who are like the best in
their craft are now rusty and they have
to figure out how to fight Javier Bardem
hair that can be really interesting but
all in all what you take away from this
trailer is that you don't really know
that much about it which I also hate it
when I talk about these trailers and I'm
like it showed too much that's the worst
I don't feel like they show too much and
there's I feel like they showed us what
we need to know to get us pumped excited
and interested I am completely
interested I want to see this movie
so the Skyfall trailer have you seen are
you excited for it and what did you
think of Casino Royale did you like it
or D but for the old-school James Bond
movies whatever your choice comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you
[Music]